Speaker 1: We're going to continue our conversations
with 2022 midterm candidates today, we will
be speaking with J.R.
Majnu Sky, who's the Republican candidate
for Congress hoping to represent Ohio's 9th
District.
J.R.
It's really great to have you on today.
Speaker 2: Thanks, Dave.
Pleasure to be here.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So so why are you running?
What led you to run?
Speaker 2: Well, you know, I lived in the
Ninth District for pretty much my entire life.
Born and raised here and I become more and
more active in the community.
And you know, I decided that with with Marcy
Kaptur being at, you know, having served office
for 40 years and you know, just the way the
country, I think is going it at this time,
I think that it's time.
It was time for someone like me to jump in
the race and some of those actually born here
and that was raised here understands the district,
you know, grew up and lived through all the
trials and tribulations that the district
has to offer.
And so I'm going to serve the country.
I think that, you know, I could be a an asset
to all the people that live here.
Speaker 1: What things would you say are not
going in the right direction in the district?
Speaker 2: Representation, I think, is one
thing.
You know, if you if you go across District
nine and talk to folks, regardless of their
political affiliation, they find many people
don't even know who Marcy is.
And, you know, having been in office for 40
years, I find that troubling.
And secondly, we're becoming more and more
of a polarized nation.
And I think getting back into the practice
of engaging in healthy political discourse
is missing.
And you know, that's something that that I've
always been about, and I really think that
we need someone to bring that behavior and
that mindset into the leadership position
of a representative for this district.
Speaker 1: One of the things that your I believe
it's your communications director, it was
your communications contact that we were in
touch with, said, was that you're a constitutional
warrior and you want to take the country back.
Can you talk about who do you want to take
it back from?
Speaker 2: I think it needs to be taken back
from the establishment from from those that
were elected by the people to fulfill, you
know, various roles of office.
But I think the people are.
The general consensus, in my opinion, is that
the people feel as if the government and our
elected representatives are extremely different
from what our expectations were when we voted
them into office.
Speaker 1: Can you give an example of that?
In other words, what would be who would be
an individual where we would say the expectation
was a and here's B, which is what they're
actually doing and we don't like it.
Speaker 2: I would say example a would be
Marcy Kaptur.
You would expect if you made a phone call
to your representative that you would get
contacted and be contacted or responded to
within a reasonable amount of time.
And I very rarely have met anyone that can
describe to me a situation where they've called
and they've got a response within 72, 48,
48, 72 hours.
I mean, some folks do not even get responded
back to.
Speaker 1: So one of your big things would
be, I'm hearing you say, I think I'm hearing
you say you would set up a system to respond
to constituents more quickly?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
One of my campaign commitments, actually my
first one, is that, you know, I hold a town
hall in every county within the district that
I represent at least once a quarter
Speaker 1: when it comes to the constitutional
piece of some of the material that we got
from you.
Are there parts of the Constitution that you
believe aren't currently being followed?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think free speech is being
trampled on right now.
And, you know, from from various outlets,
mostly from what I what I see is social media
and Big Tech.
OK, I can give examples of that.
Speaker 1: Now, just to be clear, J.R.
So our audience understands I when I said
the Constitution, when you say free speech.
Am I right to understand that you mean the
First Amendment to the Constitution?
Speaker 2: Yeah, our First Amendment.
Speaker 1: OK, right now, the institutions
you mentioned aren't governmental institutions,
and the First Amendment only applies to government.
So in what way would that apply to Big Tech
or social media?
Speaker 2: Well, generally speaking, I think
we have a right to free speech and when we
have institutions that are meant to and intended
to be a forum where public discourse can can
take place and you have arbitrary decision
makers that decide what is good and what's
bad, I think that's that is, in my opinion,
an assault against our First Amendment rights.
Speaker 1: So let's dig into that because
I think this is such a media issue where there's
so much to discuss.
Will you concede that the First Amendment
only applies to government like Twitter has
nothing.
Twitter is not governed by the First Amendment.
I hear you saying maybe you would like it
to be, but do you agree that as far as the
law is today?
Twitter in the First Amendment are not intertwined
in any way.
Speaker 2: I would say that.
I'm not I wouldn't be prepared to answer that.
Now, in the manner which I would like, I like
to look into things a little bit more.
But I would say that the general perception
is reality right in at this day and age, I
feel as if there is.
Again, I think when I post something on Facebook
and it gets taken down and it's labeled as
promoting hate speech.
When I'm just posting a picture of a meme
of someone, there's no violence and it's just
someone's face, OK?
I don't I don't comprehend how that is, you
know, promoting violence.
Or it's to me
Speaker 1: that sounds like that's your opinion
about a meme, but I guess so we can establish
a new set of facts on which we can then talk
about this.
Facebook Having terms of service has nothing
to do with the First Amendment to the Constitution
and government abridging speech, right?
You can agree with that.
So it sounds like you don't like the way some
social media companies are enforcing terms
of service.
Is that fair?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's fair.
Speaker 1: In general, as a conservative constitutional
conservative, do you favor more or less business
regulation?
Speaker 2: I'm less I would think, but it's
all it's all circumstantial.
I mean, you know, there has to be some regulations.
Not all of our businesses are automatically
ethical and principally driven.
So 100 percent,
Speaker 1: 100 percent, but in general, you
tend to favor letting businesses do what they
want to do as long as it's not against the
law.
Maybe.
Is that fair
Speaker 2: to a degree, but I mean, you know,
some some you know, some some businesses work
under the auspices of purchase agreements.
That's not necessarily law labor relations
agreements.
So I mean, you know, there's just a fine line
of of being ethical and, you know, meaning,
excuse me, meeting their their responsibilities
regardless of where that where that responsibility
stems from
Speaker 1: a 100 percent fair.
I'm with you all the way as applied.
Speaker 2: Oh yeah, go ahead.
I'm actually more of a libertarian.
Speaker 1: Oh, so even more interesting then.
So as a libertarian, would you agree that
forcing a private company like Twitter or
Facebook to have to publish your meme would
be extremely authoritarian regulation of businesses?
Speaker 2: I mean, I can agree.
I can.
I can say yes, but I mean, it's all.
It's all based on context.
You know, when?
When.
I mean, there's nothing that explicitly limits
my ability to post that meme because there
was no violation of their terms of service
as I can.
Speaker 1: So, you know, it sounds like you
disagree with the enforcement, but you're
not actually suggesting the government force
Facebook to have to let you publish it.
You just disagree with their choice.
Speaker 2: Right.
And I think I think the, you know, the arbitration
needs to be taken out of the picture.
It needs to be black and white.
There needs to be if they're going to have
rules, those rules should be, you know, enforced.
OK.
Speaker 1: You know, I think we might disagree
about how to enforce it, but I don't I don't
disagree with you in principle.
What this is just kind of like a gut check
question that I've been asking candidates
that we talked to.
And shockingly, sometimes they don't.
They're not able to answer who's the current
president of the United States, Chair Joe
Biden.
OK.
And is he?
Do you think he was elected legitimately?
Speaker 2: I think the election was stolen
personally.
Oh, you do.
I think there were extreme irregularities
with with the election.
Yes.
Speaker 1: In which states,
Speaker 2: Oh man, you got me on the spot.
I know.
Speaker 1: Well, I guess let me put it a different
way.
There is no one state that Biden won.
That's in question that would have flipped
it to Trump.
So I guess what group of states might be part
of it?
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, Georgia had election
irregularities.
Arizona, Pennsylvania, Wisconsin, even here
in Ohio, we had some.
Speaker 1: OK.
And when you say irregularities, there's been
claims levied like, for example, dead people
voted.
People voted twice.
You know, all these different things, somebody
there were, quote, massive dumps of ballots
in the middle of the night, this type of thing.
What specifically do you think happened like
in Georgia for?
And I mentioned Georgia because Republicans
oversaw that and were in charge of the election.
What do you think happened?
Speaker 2: I mean, personally, I don't speculate
on those things.
What I say is that, you know, where there's
smoke, there's fire.
OK, I believe that too.
I believe that our Congress had an obligation
to, you know, put put those concerns of a
lot of American people to rest, whether they
were right or wrong.
Our congressional members have an obligation
and the fact that we want, you know, we we've
moved forward and Congress hasn't put those
issues to rest.
That is it's just it's exacerbated the problem
where we have people on both sides of the
aisle that are that are so polarized.
I mean.
Speaker 1: Well, help me understand putting
to rest because when I do, I try to do a fair
hearing right of the claims.
Sure.
And we had 63 different state level legal
complaints filed, all found to be either without
merit or to lack standing.
And we had a variety of different investigations
take place in different states.
There was one in Georgia, there was one in
Arizona.
Sometimes it turns out Joe Biden won by even
more.
What would satisfy you?
That would quote put it to rest as you say,
Speaker 2: an audit, a full on audit of the
states that that have asked for one, if if
you know, Arizona claims that they've had
election irregularities and they are the people
there are asking for an audit, I believe that,
you know, our Congress should allow that to
move forward.
Speaker 1: But they did it, not it in Arizona.
And Biden got even more votes.
OK.
The Cyber Ninjas did.
The audit was was that audit not satisfactory?
Speaker 2: That's true.
That's true.
You're right on that.
What about Wisconsin, Pennsylvania?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I guess the question would
be if there are irregularities?
Why is it that no courts seem to agree with
that, even when it's Trump appointed judges?
You know, I'm trying to figure it out.
Speaker 2: Myself, yeah, but I mean, you're
someone of putting a slight on its Republican
this republic, I'm not looking at it in that
manner.
I'm looking at it from the people.
OK, the people are asking for it.
I mean, it's not a Partizan argument.
It's if the people believe that the election
was stolen, whether if it's they, you know,
they believe it in their hearts or, you know,
they're they're out surfing the internet and
they're running rampant on on message boards,
right?
We have an obligation.
In my opinion.
We have an obligation as the government to
put those concerns to rest.
And I, if they were put to rest, people like
me.
I mean, look, I'm I'm a very reasonable guy.
Yeah, I might be a Trump supporter, but that
doesn't mean, you know, I'm doing things that
certain folks would attribute to your rampant
Trump.
Speaker 1: No, that's why I think this conversation
is so useful.
So I guess my question would be like, what's
the threshold, right?
Because most people in Wisconsin don't think
that it was rigged in Wisconsin or that it
was stolen.
There are some people that do, but it's not
the majority.
So what should be the threshold to trigger
a multimillion dollar audit at taxpayer expense?
Speaker 2: I think I think it all comes from.
I mean, look, each state has has to maintain
their election integrity.
Right, right.
And so long as each state is satisfied and
the people aren't, I mean, you have thousands
of people that are screaming election fraud.
Maybe it's up.
Maybe it's around of of of diplomacy.
I don't know.
Speaker 1: But no, but that's I mean, that's
what I'm trying to figure out because so you've
got almost six million people in Wisconsin,
right?
Most people think the election was the results
are the real results Biden won.
If only five Wisconsin with Wisconsinites,
I don't know what the word would be if five
Wisconsin residents think it was stolen on
the basis of five people.
Should there be a multimillion dollar audit?
No, no.
OK.
What about 100?
No.
So then I guess what I'm asking is, what is
the threshold?
Speaker 2: I mean, it's not you're asking
me to answer questions that I don't believe
are relevant to.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
I mean that to me, that's a state issue.
But what I'm saying is that there's a lot
of unrest and when we came out of of of the
week when we came out of our election cycle.
Yep, right.
We should have we everyone, many people knew
that there was going to be a debate.
President Trump laid the, I guess, the the
thought process out there.
He was skeptical of the integrity of our election.
And many other folks are saying the same.
I would have expected Congress to have a plan
to recover from that, regardless of what the
Electoral College results were, right?
And we didn't they didn't do that.
We just move forward.
And there are a lot of people that feel deeply.
They feel the they.
Speaker 1: But what choice does Congress have
if there's no actual evidence of fraud that
would have changed the results in any states?
I don't.
I don't think Congress has any choice, whether
63 complaints and every court says we don't
see any merit here.
What can Congress really do?
You know,
Speaker 2: I think Congress can do a lot,
and they've proved that time after time.
They just didn't.
I mean, they investigated President Trump
for Russian collusion, for how many years,
and there come to be no evidence of that.
Speaker 1: But hold on a second J.R..
There's a difference between the investigative
authority.
Hold on a second.
But let's let's take that seriously.
The investigative authority of the house is
very different than the very narrowly prescribed
rules for how to count electoral votes, right?
Like, did you did you think, do you agree
with Trump that Mike Pence could have sent
it back to the states?
Or do you agree with the constitutional scholars
that he doesn't have that power?
Speaker 2: My understanding is he didn't have
that power.
Speaker 1: You think he did have that power?
Yeah.
What's the basis in law for that?
Speaker 2: I mean, if he had if he had the
support in the Senate from from senators that
that didn't believe that they are
Speaker 1: reasonable, but he did.
What I'm saying is given that he didn't have
the support, the support from the Senate,
what could Pence have done?
Nothing.
OK, good.
Good.
So it would have required the support to see
a lot of your colleagues don't agree with
that, including Trump himself.
Trump thinks Pence could have unilaterally
done something, but it sounds like you and
I are on the same page.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I don't understand it in
that manner.
OK.
You know, I and I don't know what, what the
context of what President Trump said other
than, you know.
So when I hear that, my impression is that
Trump felt as if, you know, he would have
had the support in the Senate and then and
then would have sent the results back.
But again, if if if he didn't have the votes
in the Senate, I don't understand how he could
Speaker 1: have done that.
OK.
I think you and I definitely disagree with
Trump on on that.
Let's talk a little bit about foreign policy.
Donald Trump was different than many previous
Republicans who were more neoconservative,
like George W. Bush, in that Trump talked
a lot about, he's going to keep us out of
wars as a combat veteran yourself and as a
Republican.
What was your sense of the kind of Trumpian
foreign policy idea of wars are bad, and I'm
going to keep us out of them.
Speaker 2: I mean, I think it's a good idea.
I think that, you know who wants to.
I mean, what kind of minded, kind hearted
American wants to to be in a war?
I mean, you know, I think wars are bad.
They're good for their good for the economy
in some respects, but they're they're bad
for our humanitarian efforts across the world.
I mean, the United States should not be engaging
in foreign wars.
I mean, diplomacy should be our go to at all
times on that.
Speaker 1: No.
Are you pleased with Joe Biden's handling
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine so far, committing
to no boots on the ground and sticking to
it as far as we can see?
Speaker 2: Yes.
I mean, I don't believe that we should be
engaging with the military effort there.
I'm a little bit displeased with the the the
the messaging that's come out in the turnaround.
You know, in talking about having a no fly
zone, sending military equipment, I mean,
to me that that that's something that I mean,
no one wants to see Ukrainians dying.
But you know, Vladimir Putin has made it very,
very clear where he stands on what he would,
what he would perceive as as a direct threat.
And he did highlight some of those things.
And I don't think we're doing enough from
a diplomatic perspective.
Speaker 1: You want to see more diplomacy,
but you're happy that we are not engaging
on the ground.
Absolutely fair.
January six, 2021.
Were you in D.C. on that day?
Yeah, I was.
And were you in the area of the capital?
Yeah.
Mm-Hmm.
Did you go into the capital?
Speaker 2: No, absolutely not.
You didn't.
Speaker 1: Did you breach barricades?
No, you didn't.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: What was the extent of your presence
there?
Speaker 2: We watched Trump speech.
We walked.
We walked on on the path to the Capitol building.
And then now in retrospect, there were some
wind fences that were that were up, but we
weren't aware of that by the time we got there.
And when we did get to the Capitol building
within, I don't know, 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
Capitol Police started to engage the crowd.
And so everybody that I was with, we just
we left.
Speaker 1: You left at that point.
Yeah, absolutely.
What's your sense of?
There's now close to maybe even more than
700 defendants to different degrees for their
involvement on on that day.
What's your sense of how they're being treated
by the justice system?
Speaker 2: I mean, from what I understand,
they're being held with the do.
I think the timely due process that they deserve
isn't isn't being afforded to them from what
I'm what I understand.
I would like to see these things expedited.
But look, this is a problem that we have across
the country.
You know, sometimes our courts are overloaded,
but you know, there's just so much discourse
out there.
There's so much messaging out there that it's
hard to see through the fog.
But I believe that these folks deserve a speedy
trial.
And, you know, many of the charges that have
been placed against them, if they've well
exceeded, I would say the penalties that they
would receive for those charges having sat
in jail for as long as they have now.
Yeah, these folks get bail.
Speaker 1: That's often a standard, right?
If you're pretrial detention exceeds the longest
possible sentence you could have based on
the charges, that that's that's a that's an
issue, a very big legal issue.
We recently spoke with with this attorney,
Steven Danziger, who was facing a similar
situation, and this pretrial detention is
an issue that many on the Left have been talking
about for a long time.
My wish J.R.
would be that people on the right spoke more
about this issue before it applied to the
Trump rioters, you know, because then then
I feel like we would really have a shared
basis to argue for some reform here.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, look, I look at these
things with the most honest perspective I
can and you know, one of my platform issues
is, you know, looking at folks that have been
abused, they've suffered some type of, uh,
I wouldn't say, abuse, but unfairness from
our justice system.
I'm particularly speaking, we have, you know,
millions of people walking around this country
right now that have had made mistakes early
in life.
And now maybe I've received a felony, but
they've committed no crime since and their
record is up for expungement and they don't
know about it.
Yeah.
You know, I'd like to see I would like to
see a federal effort that that works with
the states such that we could automate the
expungement of the records.
Because when they do find out, you know, because
they've been disassociated with, you know,
from society and from our economy for so long,
yeah, they can't afford to get back in.
And look, I grew up in the toughest and most
crime riddled, impoverished district or neighborhood
in my district.
So, you know, I got out of it and I become
successful professionally.
And so I empathize with those folks and, you
know, people that want to contribute back
to our society, back to our economy.
I mean, if they if they've if they've behaved
and they haven't broken any laws, I think
we need to be a forgiving society and we stand
by the liberty that that that we talk about
so much and we need to make it.
And we need to make the government work for
us.
Speaker 1: Hey, I'm with you on that, J.R.
I don't want to keep you too much longer,
but a couple other things.
One of the people?
Sorry.
What was it?
Speaker 2: About two more minutes.
Speaker 1: OK, one of the people that endorsed
you is Michael Flynn, and he has said, in
my opinion, some really crazy things lately,
including that that that we should be doing.
Coups and a lot of really aggressive and almost
sometimes like delusional Christian Dominionist
sort of stuff.
Is that a perspective you would bring if you
were elected or is that not really your scene?
Speaker 2: I mean, it's hard for me to answer
that, I know, I know, I know what you're asking.
Yeah.
Look, I value my relationship with General
Flynn.
He's always been a very, very respectful guy
to me.
I have not seen, I've not seen or heard what,
what you're saying.
So, you know, I think what you see with me
is what you get.
I wear my cards on my sleeve.
I understand the obligations that I have,
you know, taking this position and becoming
an elected official.
My job is to represent the people.
I think Congress is riddled with ideologies
that are looking to, you know, further pursue
their self-interest.
I'm a guy that's very young in my career,
a very successful.
And I don't need to be a representative, you
know, financially.
I'm much more better off continuing my my
career in the nuclear power industry.
But you know, again, I'm going to bring to
the table the eyes, ears and the fortitude
and willingness to help everyone in my district,
regardless of their political affiliation.
But I'm not.
I'm not going to, you know who I choose to
pursue for endorsements.
I mean, look, I've got a winner.
I mean, I'm in a contested Republican primary.
General Flynn, I consider him a patriot.
And, you know, I like General Flynn.
So you know that.
I mean, as far as the testament to his character,
I can't speak on it.
I can just tell you that when I think of General
Flynn, I think of a guy that was a very successful
general in our United States Army, and he's
always been kind to me.
And, you know, I haven't heard anything radical
that I get that I could attest to.
Speaker 1: Well, I think I'm reading between
the lines a little here, J.R. and understanding
what you're saying, but I'm glad to send you
some, some citations.
Speaker 2: Sorry, I not.
I'm not trying to dodge the question.
Speaker 1: I gotcha.
No, I understand the situation.
You're in a contested city.
I got it.
Listen, I got.
Listen, you've been eminently reasonable in
our conversation, and I think this is eye-opening.
We've been speaking with J.R.
Madejski, who's running in Ohio's 9th District,
a Trump supporter, but also a guy that we
can engage with on a reasonable basis.
J.R.
I really appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thanks, man.
I appreciate yours.
And I would say to your listeners, you know,
there's so much polarization out there right
now.
And you know, people see me, they see the
Trump line, they see the name Trump.
And you know, look, we got to we have to work
with each other.
We have to talk.
And you know this, this this one issue line
in the sand behavior and we are not as we
are Americans at the end of the day.
But even even even before that, we're human.
And, you know, we have to find a landscape
in which we can all get back together because
this this country is going down the tubes
if if we continue on the path we're on.
And it's going to take both sides of the aisle
to work together to get this done.
I don't know if that's possible the way things
are going.
But you know what, Dan and I'm going to try.
Speaker 1: So, J.R., thank you so much.
Speaker 2: You're welcome.